Baker is a fortune part of now also part
of the soggy pictures duo with Kevin k
shah and you've been explaining
something about crowd controls and I'm
curious you mentioned how crowd controls
and open in D can complement one another
and I wonder if you can touch on that
for us well later this year we have two
feature films that we want to release
direct to the audience ourselves and the
big question that's been haunting me is
you know to what audience will I be
releasing these films so finding tools
and services that will help us discover
where the demand truly is for our film
so that we can take them out to
theatrical events and by theatrical I
mean a theater but scalable all the way
down to a coffee shop that sort of thing
I wanted to find tools and services that
would allow us to find where the demand
was and a couple months ago open-end he
started their Kickstarter campaign and I
donated a hundred dollars right away so
that could be one of the first
filmmakers to be on the site when it
debuts and roughly around the same time
I started talking to a person named
brian charles who was the architect
behind the audience building tools that
fort monsters was using and he had his
own service called crowd controls that
was in private beta at the moment so i
started using both of these around the
same time and you know on a superficial
level they look very similar and I
thought you know at first glance that I
was going to have to choose one or the
other you know that I would be like sort
of like splitting the audience between
two very similar tools but the deeper I
got into them I realized that that
wasn't necessarily the case the reason
being they both deal with two components
discovery of the films and the
distribution of the films to build help
with each of those avenues whether each
waited to one or the other more so than
then the other one open in d I think
this is my opinion is going to serve as
a great tool as the community grows for
the discovery of these films and it's
also going to provide an avenue for the
distribution because people who discover
the films and are motivated can host a
screening or i can host a screening but
the audience there is sort of it's not a
closed network but it's um the people
who request your film are their privacy
is protected in that they're only going
to hear from me if a if a screening is
set up near them that will trigger an
automated email to notify them that that
there's now screening close enough to
them that they could attend crowd
controls is different in that anybody
who requests to see the films I have
access to all of their data you know I
have I can make direct contact to them
through email I know what city they're
in another zip code their postal code
but again the privacy concerns are
actually very strict with crowd controls
and that European privacy laws are very
very strict and it adheres to all of
them but crowd controls what where it's
not as strong as open in D in the
discovery element it is much stronger in
the distribution element in them because
I do have that direct relationship that
I can nurture with with people who have
requested to see the films so and that
speaks to our core strategy for
releasing the films which is prior to
release we want to gather up the
audience you know find out where they
are who they are and be able to talk to
them so that when we do release the
film's we can convert all of those two
sales and 14 min another word whether
it's tickets at the box office or DVD
sales you know we can continue to
contact them with regard to when it
debuts on cable VOD or Netflix or iTunes
that sort of things